the problem in education today is that
it's abandoned
the ground of education
students today are taught that the truth
is according to the perspective of one
that things in history are not fixed
that because we see them differently
they are different
most education today assumes that the
student is the starting point there's a
great deal of self-centeredness
there's a lack of civility a lot of
shouting
and a lack of real thoughtful
interaction so that means the only thing
wrong with education today is that it's
lost its mission
i've become convinced that one of the
greatest ways that i can impact
the future is by investing in classical
education
and helping to cultivate students into
men and women who are able to live
virtuous and wise lives
the classical model is not dead
[Music]
at hillsdale academy our motto is
virtusa sapientia
which is latin for virtue and wisdom
and that really is the backbone of what
we do here and it's really the backbone
of what a classical education is all
about
in america today i think we often think
of education as training for a
particular career or a particular
course of life a classical education is
more well-rounded than that
and it remembers that no matter who you
are there's
a moral education a character education
a civic education
and so what we're doing in the classical
education tradition is we are
drawing on the wisdom of the ages we are
exposing our students
to the wisdom that has gone before
so we don't get to make up truth just as
there are laws that govern the physical
universe
there are also moral laws one of the
challenges of education
is forming virtue
in its students and this is something
the academy excels at
things like fortitude perseverance
prudence these good virtues
are tested at school on a daily basis
i learned the importance of
responsibility and
being able to take care of the people
around me
from plato's academy onward over the
centuries learning has happened in
community
and what we have at hillsdale academy is
a community of learners
our students our teachers our staff
everyone working together
to promote the cultivation of virtue and
wisdom in our students
our daughter helen in a given semester
she's learning shakespearean drama
competing in cross-country
played violin in the orchestra this was
not a girl that was
stressed out about filling up a resume
with activities that she could burnish
her resume with to get into the college
she went to
she was just loving her friendships
and all of these things and i just see
that and think wow it has
truly been a joy to watch our children
learn
to love to learn there hardly is a day
that goes by that we are not
looking at each other with a kind of
giddiness
of gratitude for having the academy here
for this tiny school that has had 303
graduates
for 21 years straight we had at least
one student
in the national merit program there was
one year that in a class i think of 19
we had five national merit finalists i
had
three different teachers in high school
who had their phd which
i feel like is very rare this is not a
place that teachers pass through it's a
destination
it's where they want to stay it's where
they want to build their career put down
their roots
and really invest long term in hillsdale
academy
in hillsdale college and in their
students
it's not an elite school it's not a prep
school
what it is is a school that holds the
bar high
so that we can produce the best sorts of
citizens that are
our country needs so it's not just about
our little school in hillsdale
suddenly it's quite big
this is for the sake of
our nation for the sake of
just government and self-governance
everything that our country was founded
on
as hillsdale college's work in k-12
classical education continues to expand
the academy will continue to play an
incredibly important role
in that mission we want to continue
growing as a school
becoming better at the education we
provide
continuing to expand our facilities to
meet the needs
of our student enrollment growth so that
we can better serve
the mission of hillsdale college and
serve our country
as a model of what classical education
can and should be
the academy is an excellent thing and it
needs to be and so for it to be an
excellent thing it needs to be funded to
a sufficient level
education for the young is for people
who are not making a living yet
somebody has to help them and so that
partnership
between the people who support it and
the people who carry on its activity
that's natural and necessary
by supporting hillsdale academy you are
helping
hillsdale college teach
k-12 schools across the country
what a beautiful classical education
looks like and how education in this
country
ought to be done
[Music]
we're not in this to make money we are
in this to serve
the students who walk the halls of our
buildings
to bless their families but also to
bless and contribute to our nation in
the world
we are very aware that the donors
have supported that education for our
family
i was sponsored myself by a woman in
florida
who decided that classical education was
important
because of mrs mccollum i was able to go
to high school
through coaching basketball coaching
soccer and doing tutoring
i've still kept a connection to the
school and i think what keeps drawing me
back
is i've started to realize more and more
what hillsdale academy has given to me
and how much of an impact hillsdale
academy has had on my life
the reach that hillsdale academy has had
across our
nation and the educational impact is
enormous
it's got a mission to prepare citizens
to be entrepreneurs and to raise
families and to help with
other organizations because that's the
that's the backbone of a free society
[Music]
i can think of no better way to invest
in the future than by
investing in the classical education of
our young men and women
what classical schools like hillsdale
academy are doing
is cultivating students so that they can
live well
and so that they can pass on what they
have learned
to future generations a classical
christian
education is an investment in eternity
[Music]
[Music]
you